[MUSIC PLAYING]
JON FOUST: Hi, and
welcome to Episode 196
of the weekly "Google
Cloud Platform" podcast.
I am Jon, and I'm here
with my colleague, Mark.
Hey, Mark.
How's it going?
MARK MANDEL: I'm all right.
How are you doing, Jon?
JON FOUST: Pretty good.
We had a pretty long
series of trips together.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
JON FOUST: And it's kind of good
to wind down and just get back
to our listeners.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, back in
San Francisco for, like--
I don't know-- a couple of weeks
and then I'm going on vacation.
JON FOUST: Yeah.
[CHUCKLES]
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
So who are we talking to today?
JON FOUST: So yeah, we're going
to talk to Jesse Houston, CEO
and co-founder of Phoenix Labs.
And if you guys don't
know what Phoenix Labs is,
they made several games, one
of them being very successful,
being "Dauntless."
And I've played it quite a
bit, and it's pretty cool.
MARK MANDEL: It's
a pretty cool game.
Yeah, awesome.
And then after that, we've
got our question of the week,
as per usual.
We're asking me what the
difference is between premium
versus standard network.
Why would I use
one over the other?
JON FOUST: Sounds good.
So let's get into our
cool things of the week.
MARK MANDEL: Let's do that.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
JON FOUST: Our first
cool thing of the week
is virtual displays for
Compute Engine in now GA.
So what that means is when you
remote into your actual server,
your windows instance,
you can actually
create a virtual
display specifically
for your VM that's running
its own separate CPU, which
is kind of awesome,
because you don't
have to allocate GPUs for it.
So that means that this
can be less expensive.
MARK MANDEL: Very nice.
Awesome.
Speaking of going GA, cloud
native load balancing on GKE
is now generally available.
So if you're not
familiar with that,
basically if you want to do load
balancing to your containers
running on top of GKE, this is a
more efficient way of doing so.
So this is basically what they
call network endpoint group
load balancing.
Basically it means that your
traffic is going from your load
balancer directly to your
container, rather than sort
of meandering its way
around your cluster
to eventually end up at a pod.
We'll have a link in the
show notes to the blog post.
They have a great diagram
explaining this really well.
But yeah, if you want to take
it for a spin, it's now GA.
JON FOUST: That's awesome.
Our next cool thing comes from
one of our fellow developer
advocates, Mete Atamel.
He has written a blog post on
running a Windows container
app on GCE.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, nice.
JON FOUST: So it's
pretty awesome
because if you're
getting started
running containers and dealing
with containers in Docker,
this helps you run
a Windows instance.
And Mete really focuses and
targets the dot NET community.
So he goes through all of the
steps of creating a container
app and then building
a Docker image
and then deploying on GKE.
So it's kind of awesome.
MARK MANDEL: Very nice.
Very cool.
And last but not least is a
special plug out to, well,
essentially myself and
the rest of the team that
works on the Agones
project, of course.
So Agones is the
open source platform
for running multiplayer game
servers on top of Kubernetes.
You may have heard me
mention it once or twice.
We went 1.0 as of
about a week ago.
JON FOUST: Congrats.
MARK MANDEL: So this is
a really big milestone,
which is super cool.
So we now have a
stable API service,
and we're ready for
production workloads.
And we're definitely
picking up a lot more people
using it in production.
So very, very exciting stuff
for Google Cloud for Games.
JON FOUST: Awesome,
and congratulations.
MARK MANDEL: Why,
thank you very much.
Well, Jon, why don't we
go have a chat with Jesse
and talk all about Phoenix
Labs and "Dauntless"?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So this week, we are joined
by Jesse Houston, CEO
and co-founder of Phoenix Labs.
He is one of the people
behind the hot new game--
well, I don't know if
it's new, actually.
That's a good topic--
"Dauntless," which has been
doing very well lately.
But Jesse, how are you doing?
JESSE HOUSTON: I am
doing really well.
Thanks, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Excellent.
So for people who aren't
familiar with you or Phoenix
Labs, why don't you tell us
a little bit about yourself
and what you do?
JESSE HOUSTON: Yeah, so you
gave me the best introduction
that I think I've ever had.
So yeah, I started Phoenix
Labs about five years ago now.
We have been basically from the
beginning making "Dauntless."
"Dauntless" has been out
in its most recent form.
It's got a wide release,
full access form since May.
So we launched on May 21.
Prior to that, we did various
kind of rounds of betas
from an open beta last year,
and then the year prior to that,
we kind of had a closed beta.
So "Dauntless" has actually been
around for about three years,
just kind of in various
soft launched forms.
Just kind of give
you an idea of what
"Dauntless" is because I always
speak like everybody knows.
So it's called a
hunting action game.
It's about you and your
friends getting together
on any platform, coming
together, fighting big monsters
that we call behemoths.
And then you kind of
collect their bits,
and you go back into the
city, and you hang out,
and you forge new
weapons and armor.
And you go back and kill
bigger, scarier-- kind
of these big boss encounters.
JON FOUST: I remember
the open beta
when it was at Google
Cloud Next last year.
That was my first Next.
So I do remember the beta.
You did mention that
you can pretty much
play with your friends
on any platform.
So I'm assuming
that's cross-platform.
JESSE HOUSTON: Yeah.
JON FOUST: Right?
JESSE HOUSTON: Yeah,
so we're, like,
the third game ever to allow
what we call kind of the "one
'Dauntless' experience."
So the idea of, if you're on
PC and I'm on Xbox and Mark
is on PS4, we could
all play together,
and that you guys
could switch consoles,
and it would be
totally just fine.
It's a pretty crazy thing,
but we love the fact
that not only can
we play together,
but we can be on each
other's friends lists.
And we can swap back and
forth and that kind of stuff.
MARK MANDEL: Just to be
clear, I'm a PC gamer.
JESSE HOUSTON: Good.
MARK MANDEL: Not to
disparage other people
playing console, I just--
I can't play games
on the controller.
I can't do it.
JESSE HOUSTON: It's funny.
I actually play "Dauntless"
with a controller on PC.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, interesting.
Interesting.
There are certain types
of games like that,
I just end up looking
at the sky or the floor,
and that's just my life.
JESSE HOUSTON: Totally.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
JESSE HOUSTON: I feel you.
MARK MANDEL: So you said
you've been running "Dauntless"
for over three years.
It's an online multiplayer game.
So us in the industry-- oh god.
I don't want to say that.
That's awful.
But we refer to that as
kind of like a live service
online game.
It's an ongoing game.
What's that like?
Can you tell us a little bit
about what is a live service
game, and what is the
experience of running that like?
JESSE HOUSTON: We
knew from the get-go
that we wanted to be
a live service game.
Yeah, we call it a
live service game, too.
And so literally from the
first line of code written,
or the first submit,
anyways, under Perforce,
had to come with
a deployment step.
And so we started running
dedicated servers, like,
four years ago.
Initially, it was a total mess.
We do these things
called holiday builds,
or we used to do them
when we were still
in a really closed state where
we try and get everything
in just before the holidays.
And then while we did the studio
closure, everybody would play.
And I can remember in, I think
it was 2015's holiday build,
myself and the
technical director
basically get 12 hour shifts
through the entire holiday--
JON FOUST: Oh my god.
JESSE HOUSTON: --writing
Python scripts, just
to keep the game from
falling over with,
like, 150 people playing.
Not at the same
time-- like period.
[CHUCKLING] There would be,
like, 10 people playing,
and we'd have to do manual
log rotations and all
this other stuff.
That kind of experience really
taught us all of the things
that we needed kind of
progressively as we launched.
And so there's a lot of stuff
on May 21 that went wrong,
but a lot of stuff that actually
went really right because we
had been doing it kind
of progressively bigger.
And having never turned the
servers off in four years
really helps kind of
just get used to it.
A lot of companies that go
into the live environment
tend to have to all of a sudden
slow down because they're like,
oh, what is updating?
Whereas it's no big deal.
In the last two weeks,
we've patched five times,
and most players only saw
one patch, for example.
A lot of our stuff doesn't
need to take the game
servers down all the time.
And it's been a great learning
experience either way.
JON FOUST: That's
the best way to go,
not having to actually
turn off your game
in order to get a patch.
It doesn't really
mean any downtime
because I hate those games
where you have updates.
You have to wait three
hours, and I'm like,
now what do I do with my life?
JESSE HOUSTON: It's been really
interesting, that experience,
by the way.
Xbox and Playstation
don't have tools
to support that kind of
experience of the no downtime
deploys.
And so we've gotten the
opportunity to work with them
and kind of do a little
bit of teaching on our own
on what that experience can
feel like, and that it's OK,
and that that doesn't
mean that there's
going to be rampant
hacking or some sort
of other vulnerabilities.
Downtime and deploying don't
need to be the same thing.
And it's actually been a
really cool experience getting
to kind of introduce
gamers on these platforms
to that experience.
JON FOUST: Let's go back
a little bit and talk
about going from 150
gamers to a full launch.
And let's talk about scaling.
Can you tell us a
little bit how your team
went about scaling this to
support a full time launch?
And then you've
gone from 150 to God
knows how many
players you have now.
JESSE HOUSTON: Initially, when
we did everything, it was all--
everything was super manual.
So we would deploy a VM,
manually upload a build,
and initially it was
on Windows boxes only.
And it was all put your IPs in
by hand and that kind of stuff.
And then we basically
kind of just
kept iterating to add
more and more automation
through the processes.
And then as you're
flexing that and as
you're adding more players,
stuff just kind of breaks.
And so a lot of our
kind of scaling efforts
were around just
fixing what was broken
and making sure that we're then
able to see into the future
far enough that we
could kind of see
the next most vulnerable thing.
Like more recently
with SQL databases,
there was a bunch of--
our inventory was on SQL, and
we had millions and millions
of players showing up every day.
And the transaction
rates were way too high
for whatever SQL
was ever going to be
able to handle until we were
able to move over to Bigtable.
And we had to do that in a
no-downtime world as well.
So that was super
exciting, having
to write basically a service
that would check Bigtable.
And if it wasn't there,
then go get it from SQL,
and then load it
into a Bigtable,
and then give the
response back to players,
and that kind of stuff.
And so through that
whole experience,
though, we've basically
been like, OK, well,
that's the next thing
that's going to fall over.
Let's go and harden
it or re-architect it
or what have you.
And we've gone from
hardcore VM-based 2014,
2015 thought processes on how
stateful game servers should
run to--
almost everything now
runs in Kubernetes.
We were able to basically load
a bunch of stateful services
into that, and now all of our
game servers, for example,
are in CAdES.
And that's been hugely
helpful, because we
don't have to worry about
things like VM management
nearly as much.
It's just like, OK, cool.
Fire up a pod.
Put some players on it.
If the pod has a
problem, no big deal.
It can die.
And it doesn't take down
dozens and dozens of players.
It only affects four, whereas,
historically, if a VM died--
which would happen
once or twice a day--
it could take down
thousands of players.
And so we don't have
that problem anymore.
So we've been super
lucky that we've just
been able to iterate that way.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
Can you give us a sense of the--
yeah-- Jon mentioned, scale.
Can you share numbers about how
big of a player base you have,
or at least something general?
JESSE HOUSTON: Yeah.
So I think we've announced it.
So hopefully we
have-- otherwise my PR
guy is going to come at me
with the lightning bolt.
But we've got about 15 million
players who are actively
playing "Dauntless," a
great group of folks.
And that's across
the three platforms,
and we're moving into
Switch next, which
we're really excited about
all those new players coming
in, and then mobile kind
of in the next year or so.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
JON FOUST: Yeah.
I'm actually getting
it on Switch.
JESSE HOUSTON: Oh,
dude, it's so good.
Surprisingly great experience.
MARK MANDEL: So, yeah--
I mean, you've mentioned
dedicated game servers.
JESSE HOUSTON: Mm-hmm.
MARK MANDEL: Do
you have a variety
of different back-end services?
Or what does that architecture
look like a little bit?
JESSE HOUSTON: So it's
entirely inside of GCP,
and we basically have--
when a user logs
in, there's a bunch
of various accommodation
of both REST based
and gRPC calls that happen
to various services.
And those are a combination of
Java and Python microservices
that live in CAdES.
And then, once you've gone
through all that stuff,
we drop you on to a big, heavy
C++ based game server that
manages most of what you
experience as a player from
what the behemoth is doing and
where you're at, what the city
looks like, that kind of thing.
And so each of
those pods will have
anywhere from 4 to 50 players
on them at any given time.
And there are two big ones.
There's the concept of a city,
and then an island server.
And they're different, because
one requires a behemoth,
and the other one
requires lots of players,
and so we kind of keep
them somewhat separate.
And then the other is this Cloud
of other services around it,
from inventory to
store management
to persistent data storage
to telemetry and analytics
and stuff like that.
And largely we
shim a lot of calls
from basically the
client and the servers,
and we kind of farm
it out to other Google
services from BigQuery
and that kind of stuff.
JON FOUST: I would
imagine that there
has to be some type of
reasoning for taking
this type of approach
and going for it
using these back-end services.
So I'm not sure if you want
to share your secret sauce as
to why you made
these design choices.
JESSE HOUSTON:
We're pretty lucky.
This isn't the first time that
we have built a scalable game
service.
We've got a lot of folks from--
myself-- from Riot.
We've got some folks from EA.
We've got some
folks from PopCap.
And so we kind of brought
together a bunch of learnings
from previous big
AAA experiences.
And as we thought about how
we've historically built stuff,
there's always
those lists you make
at the end of any given product
cycle, where you're like,
man, I wish--
next time, I would
totally do it like this.
And the forefront of that has
always been horizontal scaling.
If I look back to some
of my previous games,
there's always that one service
that's super monolithic,
and we try and just throw
more RAM at it, or more CPUs,
and there's just no way.
MARK MANDEL: Heard
this story a few times.
JESSE HOUSTON: Yeah, right.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
JESSE HOUSTON: We've
done that, too.
MARK MANDEL: Just
rewrite it in C++.
It's fine.
JESSE HOUSTON: Yeah, exactly.
Right.
Like there's a couple of
Redis boxes lying around
in our platform still that are
very warm at any given time.
And that's not a knock
on Redis, by the way.
Redis is amazing and
has lots of good uses.
We've just been like, ah,
it just scales infinitely
on that one thread.
[LAUGHTER]
And so as we came together
and architected it,
we knew that we wanted to get a
lot more horizontal scaling in.
And so we just kind of
keep looking for that.
And also, if you think back to
the 2012 days and through 2015,
the industry was still
very much nascent
in terms of cloud hosting.
It was still
considered a bad idea.
And especially on stuff
like the idea of dev ops.
I'm trying to remember
when the Phoenix
Project was actually written.
But the idea of dev ops, for
example, was completely unknown
and things like
continuous delivery
in terms of a live
product service
were still only things that
Google and Facebook could do.
And as an indie
studio, there's no way.
And we've been really
lucky in that we're now
at of time in the industry
where a lot of those processes
are well thought
through, and they make
sense in core product loops.
And players are also willing
to get into the mindset of,
oh, if I give feedback
today, tomorrow, I might see
that change, or even faster.
So we did a big
deploy yesterday,
and one of the
players was like, hey,
this one quest line
doesn't unlock this thing.
And 30 minutes later,
we deployed the fix,
and he was like, oh, wow.
That's bloody amazing.
And it's like, nah, that's
the cool part of what
2019 can provide.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
As a particular
interest of mine,
personally, you chose Kubernetes
and GKE, specifically, even,
for running dedicated
game servers, which
is not publicly something
that people talk about.
Why did you make that decision?
JESSE HOUSTON: If I'm
being honest with you,
it's because I'm cheap.
MARK MANDEL: That's
not a bad reason.
[LAUGHTER]
JESSE HOUSTON: One
of the big problems
that come with game server
hosting is the buffer warmth.
There's all the game servers
that you've got in use,
and then stuff that's
currently turned off,
and then stuff
that's not in use,
but has to be turned on to
handle any kind of matchmaking
spikes that happen.
And my historical
life has taught me
that if I'm doing this
in stack-and-rack land,
I have to be able to have
enough capacity for my spikes,
and I have to leave them
turned on all the time,
and I'm paying the bills
and all these boxes.
And if I'm living in
VM land, VMs can take--
initially, a Windows
VM could take up
to two or three
minutes to provision,
and so we always had to
have five minutes of buffer
at any given time.
And if you think about
"Dauntless," "Dauntless's"
experience can be as low as
three-minute game sessions,
so waiting around for five
minutes to have capacity
is really bad.
So we have to keep quite a
bit more buffer than that.
And things like garbage
collection-like services
that we would install
on these boxes
can take a while, just cleaning
up logs and getting replays
off the boxes, and
all this other stuff,
and making sure everything's
in the same state.
Those processes could take
upwards of five minutes
as well.
And so we'd have to keep 10%
or 15% extra capacity online
at any given time, whereas
in GKE, I basically
can keep like 1%
extra capacity online.
I just need to make sure
that there are no completely
full boxes at all.
And given how rapid the
pods come on and offline,
there's a nice
automatic load balancing
that ends up happening.
And so I've actually--
I just keep a tiny
little bit of buffer.
And it's also super
nice-- it spills over.
So if we get a crazy
spike, like if an outage
happens, for example, in
one region, no big deal.
Players can spill over.
We can very, very,
very, very quickly
spin up capacity
elsewhere, and there
can be a really nice, tight
integration with our matchmaker
so that players
don't even notice.
JON FOUST: Awesome.
So I'm curious, because
when "Dauntless" launched--
I'm assuming that--
now, we're in 2019,
and everything's
running in the cloud.
What is the trickiest
part of scaling a game?
I've seen launches go off,
and then immediately servers
went down because they
were anticipating numbers.
JESSE HOUSTON: Oh,
that happened with us.
MARK MANDEL: Yes,
talk us through it.
JESSE HOUSTON: We had all
sorts of fun, exciting times.
I mean, so we knew a lot more
players are going to show up.
You go into consoles, there's
kind of like a validation
moment that happens.
We've got all this
PR rolling up.
We've got all these influencers.
So we know that there's a
bunch more players showing up.
And the problem that games
have that I love, but I hate,
is that there's not really a
nice, easy way of load testing
without real humans.
And so finding a
quarter million humans
or whatever to come and log
into a game before it's launched
is literally impossible.
And so we needed to basically
think about the new way.
And so we did all of the
usual stuff with load testing,
like every service has
a Locust thing that
just blaps the living heck
out of every end-point.
And we saw what we
thought our load could be.
But that's still
not representative,
and so we were able to
actually basically analyze
what real players did
in the closed beta,
and use that data
to inform bots.
And then cool parts
about Kubernetes
is we were then able to spin up
literally hundreds of thousands
of bots to play
"Dauntless" headless.
They were still real accounts,
just they didn't have graphics.
And they knew what to do
because they represented
real-life players,
and so we were
able to do just spin up
thousands and thousands
and thousands of them.
And so that actually got us a
ton of really good information.
And then it started
shutting off our video game,
and we couldn't figure out why.
And so the Thursday
before launch,
every time that we
did a bot test that
had more than 40,000
people playing in it,
it would shut off prod.
MARK MANDEL: Ouch.
JESSE HOUSTON: We'd be running
it in a different environment,
and then, all of a sudden,
prod would shut off,
and we couldn't figure out why.
Turns out, by the way, that
when you write a botnet,
anti-botnet protections
that you put in place work.
MARK MANDEL: Oh.
[LAUGHTER]
And a whole bunch of game
players looks like a botnet.
JESSE HOUSTON: Yeah, exactly.
So that took a long time for us
to figure out what was wrong.
These groups that you work with
to write these protections,
part of how they do it is they
like cut off all communication.
Yeah, so we basically DDOSed
ourselves into submission right
through the day before launch.
Finally got that fixed.
The fact is the play
patterns changed,
and a lot more people showed
up than we ever expected--
probably three or
four times more folks
showed up than any
of our expectations.
MARK MANDEL: Congratulations
JESSE HOUSTON: Thank you.
Yeah.
Great first-world
problem to have, right?
But we're really, really,
really, really concerned
with delivering a
great experience,
and so a lot of what we were
trying to do at that point
then was trying to
get ourselves back up
and running as fast as
possible, setting up
things like Bigtable, and
moving a lot of our databases
over to Bigtable,
as well as trying
to communicate effectively.
And then inching up-- cool.
Well, what if we let
10,000 more players in?
All right, cool.
We inched that up.
OK, what's the next thing that
starts to become unstable?
The launch week between
Tuesday to Tuesday,
we did 1712 deploys.
MARK MANDEL: Wow.
I thought you were-- just
kind of watching this from
the sidelines as a
fan of GCP in games--
and I thought that
you did something
that I thought was actually
really cool in terms of--
you capture players
at certain points,
and then only allowed
certain numbers in
and had a queuing system.
JESSE HOUSTON: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: That
was something I
don't think I've seen
many other people do,
and I thought that was
really interesting.
Can you talk us through that?
JESSE HOUSTON: Some
of the other games
that I've worked on in
the past, what ends up
happening when the services
get full is they just kind
of keep layering them
in there and having
a semi-degraded service
until the whole thing
kind of cascades over.
And so our thought
process was, what
if there was a very thin
version of the game that
spoke just enough of the
language of the servers
to basically leave
them in a queue,
and have enough call homes
that scaled wildly until--
and then what if
we made it so that
could take 100 times our
wildest dreams of players?
The queue itself,
for example, is--
coming back to Redis--
it was basically a
little Python app that
had like 500 lines of code
that just touched a Redis box,
and had kind of-- whenever
you got put in a queue,
depending on where
you are in the queue,
it would basically say
to the client, hey, cool.
Come check back in in
X number of seconds.
Here's where you are in line.
Because at one point, I think
we had 300,000 players in queue,
and we were accepting
like 50 players
a second or something
like that into the game.
And so that queue
was quite long.
And just the act of
checking the queue
would have taken down the
service all by itself.
And so we actually had to kind
of write in this graceful fall
off or whatever so it'll
only check back in once every
three or four minutes, when
you were more than an hour
in queue, and that
kind of thing.
The nice thing
about that, too, is
we can also overload the
messages that the queue would
tell players.
Like if something was
really going wrong,
we could change the
text in that box
and say, hey, we're
having this other problem,
so queue times are
going to be even longer,
and that kind of thing.
And that's been
really, really helpful.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, nice,
JESSE HOUSTON: And then
anybody that actually made it
through the queue got a
reward, these little titles
that are in your game.
So we also recorded all the
players who sat the queue
and made it through, and so
a message that you would get,
the error code, was called
QueenBee, queue blocked.
And so the title that
you would get in the game
is Slayer of the Queen.
JON FOUST: That's awesome.
So I can imagine that,
given all of the things
you had to go through
at launch, that there
had to be some people that
you had to reach on our end
to actually help you with
the launch and any type
of other integration
that you had to do.
So I'm curious about how our
professional teams helped you
out.
And I'm not sure
exactly which teams
you actually met with, but--
JESSE HOUSTON: Oh.
JON FOUST: --hopefully you
could speak to that just a bit.
JESSE HOUSTON: Yeah, for sure.
So we've had a great
relationship with the GCP folks
since open beta launch.
Actually, our account
manager was there
when I pushed the big button
on open beta 18 months ago
or whatever, and he actually
brought the champagne.
And so we basically
got the opportunity
to work with the CRE team,
and the GCP technical account
managers, and the
service account managers,
and stuff like that,
through the build up to.
And that gave us a lot of
insight of what could fall over
and what couldn't.
The weekend before launch,
when we were running into the,
we don't know why our
game isn't turning on
because we're DDOSing
ourselves, for example, we
had five folks from CRE and from
the GCP technical team on site,
and they stayed up all
night with us helping.
We set up desks in the war room.
We have basically a big
common space in the studio
that we normally use for mo-cap.
We basically set up 15 desks.
And then, as launch happened,
everybody was on site
with us helping call the shots.
We had a dedicated
Google Hangouts PC
with a big monitor that was
kind of pointing into the room
that folks from Google
could phone in and help.
Then, at one point,
we had something
like 50 Googlers supporting
us during the launch.
It was really awesome.
I have the
opportunity of working
on a relatively cool thing,
like working on games
is kind of interesting.
And so as folks kind
of heard that we
were doing this thing, and--
at one point, we had folks
from the GCP Linux kernel
team heard that we were
having a kernel panic
issue because of some reason.
And next thing I know, I've
got some dude that understands
how all that crazy
business works,
and he's writing
kernel patches for us
just because it's interesting.
And he couldn't log in,
and he's like, well, I've
got nothing better to do.
Let me go and fix
your kernel panics.
And it's like, great!
Let's go!
It was really wild.
Folks were coming in
from all over the place.
We got custom versions of the
Kubernetes Masters written
for us, because we
were putting a load
on the Masters like no one
at Google had ever seen.
And we were basically
turning on and off
so many pods per
second, at one point,
our Master was getting something
like 2,500 requests per second,
and it's like two
orders of magnitude
bigger than Google had
ever seen before, even
on their own services.
And they're like, well, OK.
I guess we have to make
a Snowflake version,
as it was called, for you guys.
And so it was super supportive.
Everybody from
capacity planning--
we were 3x off what our
craziest numbers were,
and so we had the
capacity planning
folks phoning in going,
just finding servers for us.
And every time that
we would find servers,
eight hours later,
the problems shifted
to a new area of the world.
And so they were
coming back online
to find us more servers
for throughout the world.
And it was a really
awesome experience overall.
MARK MANDEL: Now,
that sounds great.
I'd love to know, as well, even
more about that CRE experience.
Were they highlighting
things that you're
like, this stuff is amazing?
And then, were they
like, this part--
they're like, hm, I don't know?
Or what did that
whole thing look like
as you engage with CRE?
JESSE HOUSTON: Yeah.
So over the six months towards
launch, they would come on site
and take a look at our
tech stack with us,
take a look at the
usage patterns,
and go, hey, have you
thought about maybe
not using Cloud SQL for all
of your off-end inventory?
It's going to be fine.
We load tested it to like
8 million, bazillion.
And they're like, yeah, cool.
No, that's not going to work.
[LAUGHTER]
Have you thought about Bigtable?
Nah.
We don't need Bigtable.
The old ways, that's
the right stuff.
No, no, no.
No.
It's not the right stuff.
OK.
Sure.
Cool.
Then, sure enough, yeah--
it was the wrong choice.
Bigtable was the right way.
But a lot of it was just
them coming on site,
being able to leverage all of
this institutional knowledge
that's built up at Google
and with other partners,
and really kind of just poke
really gentle holes in what we
were building in our
thought processes,
and giving us a
lot more context.
And we basically
just kind of came
up with this very
prioritized list of stuff
that we needed to fix.
And the issues that
we had on May 21
were just the next stuff that
we couldn't get to in time,
which was really super awesome.
Because the stuff that
was way above there
was way harder to
fix, so stuff that we
could turn around in under a
day ended up being the stuff.
And so they basically
continued to pay attention
through the launch, and started
projecting out going like,
hey, as an example,
we were using--
so, again, in SQL--
SQL was the bane
of our existence.
I think.
We were doing binary logs
for all of our transactions.
And at one point,
we got a call--
I think it was on Friday
after launch-- going, cool.
So you're going to run out of
hard disk space on the largest
instance that Google can
make just due to binary logs.
Your whole service is going
to fall over in three days.
MARK MANDEL: Small problem.
JESSE HOUSTON: It's like, cool.
Thank god you called.
We've got three days.
All right.
How do we fix this?
And it's just been that
kind of thing where,
while we were kind of eyes
deep in the immediate fire,
the CRE team ended up
just kind of having that
one-week-plus-out perspective,
and spent time coming up with
solutions to like, oh, OK, cool.
Instead of this, do
this other thing.
And when it got really crazy
they opened up various editors
and were supporting us directly.
So it was pretty cool.
JON FOUST: That sounds awesome.
Glad you could cooperate
with a lot of people.
And it's kind of funny how
games bring people together,
isn't it?
JESSE HOUSTON: Right.
We always talk about
that in the product side,
but never in the
development side.
At least, none of the
companies that I've ever
worked with before had
the presence of mind,
or the openness to invite
other companies to support,
and it was really sweet getting
to work with Google on the fact
that, because they're
just like, we'll happily
come into your house and
help you, just open the door.
And we're like, yeah, come on.
Please.
JON FOUST: Just wipe your feet.
JESSE HOUSTON: Yeah.
Right.
Come on in.
I beg you.
So it was a good experience.
JON FOUST: That's awesome.
So I'm curious-- if you
could do this all again--
I mean, granted you let
us into your house--
JESSE HOUSTON: Yeah.
JON FOUST: What is the one thing
that you would do differently?
What is the one thing
you would possibly
change if you have something?
JESSE HOUSTON: You know, that's
such a weird loaded question,
because--
[LAUGHTER]
--the way I look at that is
like, what didn't we see?
The assumption there is
that I'm smarter today
than I was yesterday, or that
I had inherently bad judgment
then.
But I don't think I would
have changed anything.
Given the knowledge
that we had, I
think we did a really good job.
I think if I could
have seen or learned
something ahead
of time, I think I
would have liked to have done a
better job with log management.
I know that's really
explicit, but there
were a couple of
things that took
a little longer for
us to identify because
of how we did log management.
As an example, it took
a long time for us
to load testing back online,
because we didn't know
that we were DDOSing ourselves.
That was in the logs
from the first outage.
We just didn't see it.
We didn't know what to look for.
We didn't know what to
read, these 415 errors
that were getting spat out.
It wasn't until--
I think it was Sunday
night or Monday,
really, really early
in the morning,
that one of our engineers
was like, what's error 415?
It's like, I don't know--
Google search away--
and, oh, [BLEEP]..
[LAUGHTER]
But it took multiple
days before we got to it,
because we were just like--
we just didn't do
a good job there.
The other thing that I think I
would do personally differently
is--
I don't think my
career really taught me
a lot about crisis management.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, interesting.
JESSE HOUSTON: And so
in the minutes of sleep
that I was getting, or
the minutes of downtime
that I was getting
post launch, I
was doing a lot of reading
about how firefighters actually
manage crisis.
And even just that small
amount of learning that I
got in that week in terms of--
I noticed a thing.
OK, cool.
Who does this really well?
OK, firefighters do.
OK, quick-- go find
literally a textbook
on how to be a fire
captain, and how
to think about how to
put a burning house out,
and how to tell folks to
go and do the right work.
Just that a little bit of extra
knowledge was really critical.
And if I could have learned
something ahead of time
that I'm more
intelligent about now,
I would have liked
to have been better
at crisis management, just as
a general leadership trait.
A lot of leadership folks and
technical leadership manuals
and blog posts, and
all this other stuff,
talk a lot about
vision and empowerment,
and all this other stuff, that I
ascribe to really aggressively.
But on the other hand, when--
for lack of a better
term-- when [BLEEP] hitting
the fan and the building's
literally on fire,
that's a very
different set of skills
than trying to expose a
vision, and getting up
in front of teams, and
this kind of stuff.
And it definitely highlighted
a personal weakness for me,
where just literally
keeping folks
on task, on the right
stuff, and not accidentally
get people into a flail-y
place, and that kind of stuff.
I'm continuing to invest more
of my personal growth time
on that kind of stuff.
JON FOUST: Awesome.
MARK MANDEL: What's coming next?
Can you tell us about
what's coming next,
or anything freaking cool?
JESSE HOUSTON: Yeah.
There's a lot of really
cool stuff coming.
We've just announced our
next weapon with Nintendo.
So we're obviously coming
to Switch this year.
There's not many months left
in this year, so it's soon.
It's a lot of fun.
We just showed it at PAX.
There's a whole bunch of new
expansion content coming up.
We're-- the way describe it,
we're just getting started.
We'll probably come
out of early access--
or whatever we're calling the
game right now-- soon-ish,
and just kind of keep pumping
in more value into it.
The team is tipping
and rearing to go,
or however that saying is.
MARK MANDEL:
Something like that.
JESSE HOUSTON: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
JON FOUST: So we'd
like to ask you
before you go, is there
anything that we missed
that you might want to mention?
MARK MANDEL: Are you going to
be anywhere in particularly?
Do you want people to come find
you, or anything like that?
JESSE HOUSTON:
Obviously, anybody
who's keen on "Dauntless,"
feel free to give it
a try at playdauntless.com.
I, personally-- I'm going
to be giving some talks over
at the Montreal International
Game Summit in November
on leadership and growing
teams and companies
and lessons learned,
and that kind of stuff.
Otherwise, we've got
a bunch of GC talks,
as well, that
we've done that are
recorded on how we
scaled "Dauntless,"
and how we built it.
Feel free to check those out.
They're really cool.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
JON FOUST: So I have
one personal question
before we let you go, because--
JESSE HOUSTON: Oh.
JON FOUST: --you're probably
the second CEO of a game
that I've talked to.
How many hours have you
logged in "Dauntless?"
JESSE HOUSTON: Oh, my
god how many hours have I
logged in "Dauntless?"
Thank god, we don't
have a /played command.
[LAUGHTER]
Probably more than
I'd like to admit.
We used to actually have
this counter at the studio
for number of Drask kills.
So Drask is this kind of big,
green, scaly lightning lizard
thing.
It was the first
production-quality behemoth
we had.
I was the first at the
studio to 1,000 kills.
And those fights used to
take 20 minutes long, so--
and then I stopped letting
us use the counter,
because it was either
non-productive or
life-destroying--
one of the two.
Probably not the most
played versions since May
at the studio, for sure.
That probably goes
to either Quentin,
one of our web devs, or maybe
Tanner, one of our artists.
Quentin's max-level
gear on everything,
and he rivals some of
our best streamers now.
I can punch with
the best, but not
as much as I used to, sadly.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
All right.
Well, Jesse, thank you so much
for hanging out with us today.
It's been a pleasure
talking to you.
JESSE HOUSTON: Oh,
hey, it's my pleasure.
Thank you so much for having me.
JON FOUST: See you.
JESSE HOUSTON: All right.
And take care, guys.
JON FOUST: So we want
to give a big thank you
to Jesse Houston for joining
us on this week's podcast.
Very, very interesting
conversation
on how "Dauntless"
and Phoenix Labs got
started on GCE, other
headaches they've got,
and all the things
they had to go through.
And it's kind of awesome to
see one of our success stories,
especially in games.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
JON FOUST: So let's get into
our question of the week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So our question of
the week is, what
is the difference between
Premium and Standard network?
MARK MANDEL: Oh, this
is a good question.
So this is fun.
So way back in the day,
there was but one network.
And there was only
one network to choose.
And that was what we currently
refer to now as Premium Tier
networking.
So the short answer
here is the way
Google's network works is we try
and get you on to our network
as fast as possible.
So we have how much
of our own fiber,
and that runs under the
water, and all that kind
of cool stuff.
So we basically try and get
you from your internet service
provider directly to
our points of presence--
we have over 100
around the world--
and then get you inside
the Google network,
where we can control everything.
It runs over our own network,
and it works really nicely.
This is the Premium Tier.
This is basically high
performance routing.
We're able to do some other
things, like have our Cloud
load balancing to be global.
I have global SLAs,
things like that.
This is basically what you
want when you want performance,
super fast.
But what we also have is what
we call Standard Tier, which
is very similar to basically
what a lot of other cloud
providers provide,
wherein you spend
the vast majority of your
time over the public internet.
So you're not running
over our network.
It's just going to
be a little slower.
You're going to have
a little bit less
of a consistent experience.
But it's cheaper.
This is where we're not going to
try and get you on our network
as fast as possible.
We're going to leave you
on the public network.
And so you're going to be
on a low performance tier,
but it is cheaper.
So maybe if cost is what
you're trying to optimize for,
the Standard Tier
could be really good.
But if speed is what
you're looking for,
then the Premium Tier
could be really good.
And you can choose either one
as you see fit for each workload
as you require it.
So it really depends
on what your needs are.
JON FOUST: Awesome.
So, Mark?
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
JON FOUST: Where are
you going to be going?
MARK MANDEL: Where am I going?
What am I doing?
That's a good question.
So, first, I'm going on
vacation in a few weeks.
So I'm very excited about that.
JON FOUST: [LAUGHS]
Well deserved.
MARK MANDEL: Well,
I hope so, yes.
It's will overdue.
So I'm doing that.
And then, after I get
back from vacation,
I will be at KubeCon, as I
know you will be as well.
JON FOUST: Yes, I will.
MARK MANDEL: I believe we're
doing some workshops-- probably
some Agones and some
Open Match workshops
for anyone who works
in the games industry,
probably be floating
around in a bunch of talks,
and stuff like that as well.
Literally, I just got
back from finishing
a bunch of other things,
so I haven't actually
made all my plans
for KubeCon yet.
There's more stuff
coming, I'm sure.
But come and say hi, either way.
JON FOUST: And I also
will be a at KubeCon,
and I will be doing all of the
above that Mark just mentioned.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
JON FOUST: And I will be
attending several weddings
in the upcoming months.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, exciting.
JON FOUST: All of
my friends decided
to get married together,
so that means more flying.
MARK MANDEL: That works.
That works.
But, yeah-- we'll make sure we
have some Google Cloud Platform
Podcast stickers, especially.
I need to bug one of
our friends, April,
and make sure that we have
some Agones and Open Match
stickers to hand out as well.
JON FOUST: I definitely
need the new Open Match one.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, definitely.
All right.
Well, Jon, thank you
very much for joining me
on the episode this week.
JON FOUST: Thank you very much.
It's been a pleasure as always.
And we would like
to thank you all
for listening on this episode.
Have a good time, and
see you next week.
MARK MANDEL: See you later.
[MUSIC PLAYING]